[Music]
my name's Miles Morales I'm Brooklyn's
one and only Spiderman and things are
going great
he's gonna be here any minute it should
be simple enough give me your money so
are you like a cow or a Dalmatian
Spider-Man
I am the spot
that's not funny
don't don't do that
there's bubbles now hold on
I don't think I want this costume
anymore huh in a minute hey what did all
this one word that's cute right the
youth how's this going nice
grades are pretty good A and AP Physics
that's my little man and a B in Spanish
what okay miles
want to get out of here
welcome to spider Society
Spider-Man oh no way all of us are
me
it's like a ninja vampire Spider-Man but
a good guy plus he's like such a good
leader miles there's moments in our
stories that are the same for all of us
some good did you bring our baby to
another fight I knew I was gonna regret
making her that web shooter you asked me
not to so I didn't I wouldn't it's in
bed you have a choice between saving one
person and saving every word
that's an obvious choice
I can't do that I can do both
everyone keeps telling me how my story
is supposed to go nah I'm gonna do my
own thing
can this day get weirder
I guess it can
there's nowhere to run
my bad everybody there was somewhere to
run
[Music]